[Music]
all right john yes john where'd you grow
up where are you from um i'm originally
from dover delaware born 1990
32 years old tell me about your family
you had a mom and dad growing up um i
lived with my parents in hartley
delaware um
until i was 12 years old
growing up
it was
it was okay when my dad wasn't drinking
um he was you know quite the alcoholic
him and my parents fought all the time
when he was you know
um
you know when he wasn't sober
uh when he was sober we would do you
know going camping trips
um go to the beaches all the time and
stuff like that and we had fun but at
night time is just when
i i'd always want to go to my room
there would be a lot of physical
fighting and i could hear just like my
mom screaming and
i remember one incident specifically
that i didn't know what to do my mom was
screaming for me to call 9-1-1 and
my dad was telling me not to and i was
afraid of my dad so i was afraid he
might retaliate on me so i didn't call
and i didn't know the severity of the
situation or anything
luckily nothing came of that but that's
just an example of how bad things got
there
there's been times where my mom took me
and my sister have a younger sister um
she's nine years younger than me
and um
there's times that she would take us to
her mother's house to you know get away
from him when he's got extremely violent
and starting her and stuff like that
in 2002
he uh
he got accused of molesting my sister
and
about three months after that he got out
on bail
and he broke into
where my mother was living there our
house
and he shot her in himself
and that's how i lost my parents i was
12 years old and my sister was three
she was there when it happened i was
staying at my grandmother's house
because of i was trying to go to a
different school
but yeah i heard the news the next
morning and i just felt completely numb
um
but yeah
so ever since i was 12 i you know lost
my parents and i lived
i was raised from my uh my dad's mother
my grandmother at that you know their
onsens
wow
it's heavy um
but yeah i proceeded to go to school my
grades weren't the best around that time
but come high school
i started to focus a lot on on my
schoolwork and i
graduated high school
um
lived a normal life for the most part i
had to go to uh counseling throughout
all those years
um
which helped a lot um you know being a
rebellious teenager sometimes i didn't
want to go or participate in that i'm
like i don't need this you know
but um
but i'm glad i did it it taught me a lot
of
coping strategies
and things of that nature
when it came to me getting upset
i did i was actually quite an angry teen
soon after the deaths
i'm not sure exactly how that spawned
but
after i realized the destruction of what
i was doing i really took a step back
and focused on myself
and i i never let myself get to that
that type of nature again
and ever since that i had inner peace
with myself and was able to live a
normal life what kind of stuff were you
doing as a team um
as far as the anger yeah um
well i would get grounded for having bad
grades and i would take like
my computer which i got ground from and
throw it against the wall and you know
bust holes in the wall
and i remember i was ready like i was
clinching my fist ready to punch
my own grandparents which i would never
do
and that's when i realized that things
were really getting bad and i'm like i
can't you know i can't do this i don't
want to hurt them
and
it was that was pretty much a turning
point when i started to calm you know
calm myself down so you got yourself
under control yeah
right when i knew i was about ready to
strike them
after after high school yeah i graduated
high school and
i proceeded to go to
delaware tech it's a two-year community
college
i forgot to mention
throughout
since i was about eight years old i've
always had interest in computers
and
and specifically developing software for
them so that was something that i've
self-taught myself throughout those
years
um just from reading online articles i
for example i was eight years old when i
wrote my own web page just
basic html things you know making uh you
know text boxes or whatever nothing
functional of that nature but i still
was able to make a web page out of
straight html when i was eight
and then you know progress from there i
started making you know scripts for
games and stuff like that throughout my
teenage years so anyways when i got to
college i wanted to take something
related to computer programming because
i enjoyed doing the type of work
and so i went to you know delaware tech
flew through that
with flying colors it was all pretty
easy except for like you know literature
english classes that you just have to
take
but i graduated magna [ __ ] laude which is
the top 10 of the class
um
and through an internship while i was
still attending college i started this
job at a place called zone laser tag
and
i ended up working there for 10 years
as a software developer and ended up
being electronic engineer just through
the experience with the work that we did
there
i met my wife in high school
in 10th grade
so i was 16
she was 16. i'm a little bit under a
year older than her
and we were together since
uh we got we ended up both going to
college um
she took up nursing while i took up
software development
um
by the time we were 24 we went and
bought our own house or 23 i'm sorry i
was 23. we went and got our own house
moved out of my grandparents place
and
things were going great um
about a year later we decided to have a
kid
so
when i was 24 i had my son johnny
[Music]
things started to take a little toll on
our relationship with the new baby and
all that so we we did fight a little bit
just over you know how it should be
raised and who gets to take care of them
when one's trying to sleep because she
worked night shift and stuff like that
but nothing that we couldn't control but
you know it did take a little toll on
our relationship
um
[Music]
and then
what is it not even my son was born in
may of 2014
by december of 2014 we found out she was
pregnant again
with then what would be my daughter
savannah she ended up being born august
26th of 2015.
um
and then to my surprise or our surprise
she
was three days old when we found out she
had stage four cancer neuroblastoma
um
[Music]
so we were distraught you know we heard
stage four we're like
that sounds pretty dangerous how are you
going to lose our daughter and things
like that nature
but we took its course and kept our
hopes up and
she took a whole year of chemo
and
after a year she
was finally declared in remission as in
the cancers basically
stop growing metastasizing and it's
the tumors are still there but they're
not cancerous anymore basically
so we were proud to hear that um she
does get scans every six months to make
sure it doesn't come back
that is one of my greatest fears
um
[Music]
so other than that about a year and a
half
after she beat her in battle
her mother
went to the doctor with pain in her hip
and the last thing she expected to hear
was that she also had cancer as well
and what was causing the pain in her hip
was the cancer had eaten through her hip
bone she had holes in her hip
and you know they did the rest of the
scans of her body and it
already progressed everywhere
and they basically said she only had
about six months to a year to live
and they said if even if we try to treat
it we might be able to extend your life
by maybe six months
um
so of course we still try to get
treatment we're not gonna you know she
wasn't gonna give up without a fight
um
and we had issues trying to get
insurance to approve it and all that she
only ended up getting one treatment
but uh
sadly a year and a half later she passed
away
um her mom and sister was trying to help
her to the bathroom and she had fainted
and stopped breathing
and they got her back because they were
also her sister is also a nursing
student
they had got her back got her to the
hospital and then she passed away there
so soon after my wife died um
i decided to
pack up and move here to los angeles to
start a new life
with your kids um
my kids
so about a month before
she passed she had given the kids to her
brother because we weren't really
getting along at that time
so my my kids currently reside with her
brother in pennsylvania
um
[Music]
i do video chat them once every week
though just to stay in touch
um once i get established out here i
would like to try to get them back
um
and they're always excited to you know
see me and call me and stuff like that
so they haven't forgotten about me or
anything like that we still have a good
communication contact
with each other how many years has it
been since your wife passed um it was
september of 2020 so a year and a half
yeah
september 2nd 2020. you're still reeling
from it
yeah i was definitely distraught for a
while there um
i i did start abusing drugs
specifically opiates
quite hardcore after that
because you know
i didn't want to feel anything
that happened before you came to la or
after um
[Music]
after because i tried to keep
my integrity in line but
you know as
as i wasn't staying busy i started to
get stuck in my head and
and that's a bad place a dangerous place
to be
so
i ended up
basically i had to live on the streets
for a while and that's all i was around
and i easily just started picking up on
the usage
so i i have seeked out treatment to the
methadone clinic
and i attended that for a year
and
the reason they had to discharge me is
because i didn't have my medi-cal
approved
and once they found that out because
they they were trying to work with me
you know um
let me slide for a bit until i get it
you know approved and whatnot but i had
i guess let it slip and they had to do a
discharge and
they did a two-week taper and
near the last week i started to use
again because i got scared of the
withdrawals that were coming on
um and
i still use to this day now
i have since gotten medi-cal and i do
plan on seeking treatment here soon
where are you staying now
i just got into a shelter
the union rescue mission
where have you been staying um but prior
to that i was in a tent
uh what had happened was two months ago
i had gotten a really bad infection
and i was in hospital for 17 days with
sepsis
and um
that's what got me in this this whole
path that got me into the shelter um
and but prior to that i've been in a
tent since i've moved out here to la
so i'm trying to stay a house as long as
i can
um they got all the resources that i can
call and you know get connected with the
right people and all that so i'm trying
to stay house as long as possible
it keeps me away from all the um
all the you know drugs and stuff on the
street all that activity
how do you support yourself now
right now i'm just living off of state
benefits
as far as food stamps goes and
[Music]
i'm trying to find work
uh
i've been putting in applications
um it's kind of hard to work with an
opiate addiction though
yeah um because especially if you have
to find your fix every morning before
going to work
um
so
i yeah you're right i believe i should
probably work on cleaning myself up
before i commit to um
my job yeah
what do you worry about now what are you
afraid of i'm sorry what are you afraid
of
um
honestly not much
after what you've been through
you've been through a lot yeah
um but
i guess my biggest fear would be not
being able to support my kids
you know emotionally and
just being there for them
and like i said earlier one of my
biggest fears is my daughter's cancer
possibly coming back
because she was still young when it
happened and
she has all these years to live that she
still has to get scanned and make sure
it doesn't progress
and i'm just you know afraid i get that
phone call one day
you
know after you've been being through
what i've been through you just kind of
like half expect it like
it's just a really scary feeling
what is going through
losing your parents is
the way you did and then losing your
wife so tragically what what is
what does all that teach you
well most people never experience either
of us yeah well one is to not take life
for granted and live today like it's
your last
um
always
treat everyone with um like like it's
your last time talking to them because
you never know when they will
because of course there's things i wish
i could have said or done you know
if i had known that they were
you know seconds away from passing and
stuff like that
which
of course no one's ever gonna know but
like i said you always want to be on
good terms with everyone i never try to
hold grudges or anything like that
so
like i said
stay on good terms with everyone
and
yeah
yeah it's great
but what emotions do you go through
now that you're
in this situation
um
i try not to let myself get depressed
because
and i know that's way easier said than
done
because i'll end up getting in the
slouch and not doing anything
um
i don't have any anger or resentment
it's
which a lot of people do when they
experience loss i i don't i just feel i
mean that sounds typical but you expect
i just feel sad
[Music]
let's see
you believe in god
i was raised catholic
um
i had phone i have fallen away from the
church and look at it more at a
scientific view
um so i'm not as religious as i once was
it'd be hard to after what you went to
right yeah i do
i i just don't understand how a god
could place a child on this earth you
know dying of cancer and
just a bunch of bizarre things that i
don't believe a god would do
obviously you know he's known for
putting people through their tests and
stuff like that but
i i don't know your tests are pretty
tough yeah
what was your favorite memory in your
life your favorite memory in your life
um
i'd have to say just being on the
camping trips with my parents and my
sister
because those were you know one of the
good times that we had um
we had fun
um
i mean i guess that's really a point in
life before i experienced any kind of
you know traumatic events as such
so that's definitely one of my happiest
memories that i can remember before i
had any kind of emotional damage
did you see a therapist about any of
this
um
after my parents died i've seen a
therapist for probably about six years
straight
um i did go to therapy about
six years ago um for maybe about six
months
um
it didn't really feel like i had much to
talk about because i already knew all
the coping strategies stuff like that
and i was adhering to them pretty well
it's just sometimes i'll fall out of
that
that loop of uh routine
of doing what i i was doing in other
words i was going to the gym and going
bowling i was always staying busy didn't
have time to sit and think and
i didn't have time to uh you know sit
there and and think about uh all the bad
things that have happened and stuff like
that um as long as i stay busy i was
you know pretty pretty well off
and the fentanyl addiction is going to
be a tough thing to to break free from
it is are you afraid are you afraid you
you might be stuck here
no i know i'm not stuck i'm just
not head strong enough to really say all
right
this has to happen or else i'm gonna die
um
i have gotten to that point before
and like i said i slipped up
um
and i still haven't recovered back from
that yet um
i just need to
honor i just need to really put my
priorities in order and and say you
can't live this life forever
and something's got to change
which i feel like i'm pretty close to
getting to there
you have any regrets in your life
um
i try to live life with no regrets
if i had to pick one i would say
um
about a day before my wife passed we
were supposed to all video chat with her
and the kids all together
and i missed that call i forget why i
want to say i was still sleeping or
something because the time difference
but i do regret missing that
because that would have been our last
time as a family to all be together
[Music]
other than that i really don't have any
regrets
what do you think of that saying that
people say uh
god doesn't give you anything
that you can't handle even given a lot
to handle
well i mean
i don't think there's anything that can
happen that'll push me over the edge per
se to
you know make me want to end it or
anything like that
even if you know i was losing my whole
family and
i don't know i i feel like i've already
been to rock bottom and nothing else can
really push me down any further you're
pretty resilient
i suppose yeah
but what helps you
survive after i mean i know you're
you're addicted to fentanyl now that's
not that's not good but
no um
what gives me the drive to keep going
yeah what keeps you going
um
just knowing that i've you know i've had
everything before and i know i can get
back to that point
[Music]
i guess if if that hadn't happened
[Music]
not knowing what it is like to you know
have everything and and you know in
order
i suppose it would be easier to give up
but knowing that i've already been there
before and it's i can easily access or
get to that point i know the steps i
need to take
i think that's what keeps me going is
knowing that's a possibility and i i can
get there if i really put my head to it
hope is a great thing to have isn't it
yeah
all right john thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck
thank you
you